okay let's try it Sicilian and okay mmm
all right let's get my night oh okay
the Grand Prix is happening so let's go
with this sometimes I like to establish
it's not the easiest thing to do but I
like to establish maybe upon on this f5
square and is this I gonna backfire on
the bishop if I could get this advanced
in successfully um me let's see if I
could get this in I could get it in and
if this pawn takes I think white has no
advantage can i really say that so
confidently I think so I think so
so I think if there was an engine here I
think you would see a shift in the
evaluation with this pawn captures I
don't know that that would be the nut
the top move the reason I say this is
because of the new squares that are now
available for my pieces in particular
it's the bishop or the night that can
make use of f5 but it's not limited to
just that Bishop g4 is often quite
annoying I think I do well to just first
sidestep just our outside stuff but just
Castle complete my development and get
out of this pin but my other thought is
maybe just play here first before maybe
it's prevented but actually no no no
because what I could be doing is if this
pawn move ever is played
my knight can maybe get to g3
f4 is is very weakening you have III as
soon as he moves its g3 and really my
main idea here is just to develop to g4
be anointing and follow up with Knight
d4 in fact if white is not careful that
Bishop could maybe be lost so now with
that I have the bishop pair and I see no
reason to fracture my structure so I
just recapture and this is really the
main square that I want to be aware of I
really don't want to allow this Knight
to sit here and be annoying the furthest
advance the farthest advanced pawn that
my opponent has is the one that I really
focus on the most when it comes to
support points for the pieces this guy
right here is lending support for two
well support points in G v e5 both of
which are in my territory so just a
tempo gainer tempo gainer on that Queen
and now maybe it's time to weasel around
with my knight or what about this this
is a sensitive point is it not
this Knight I'm not too concerned about
this this Bishop is gonna have a hard
time developing can't really go here for
the rook maybe in some lines a pawn push
most directly the rook but anyhow what
do I do
Knight to f5 I would really like to have
him there or should I just centralize my
knight right here allows Knight e5 but
after a night here am I not winning this
actually you know what I'm not gonna do
that I think there might be a line where
there's a pawn sacrifice if I if I go
here maybe the knight jumps in here
maybe I do get this Knight but I'd have
to give up my very valuable dark-squared
bishop I don't know that I really want
to do that so maybe what's better is to
play here let me do that let's get rid
of this pesky night then I don't have to
worry about him jumping into my
territory
it's the e5 square of these of these two
I think it's the e5 square that has a
bit more of my concern
so not really it's a very forcing move
something needs to be done here they're
gonna have a knight exchange or my
opponent will it end up having to
babysit upon c2 that's not really
something you should want to do and you
know another thing is why why was I just
thinking in Reverse like this why was I
really thinking about getting - maybe f5
by way of East 7 when I could have a
more aggressively placed night
you see that there's two different
avenues towards that f5 Square and I was
fixated on e7 prior to d4 and this is
gonna be a problem now because theta 5
is going to set up an annoying
discovered attack against the Queen
pretty much I could force it where she
has to play on one of these light
squares if Queen g5 I could consider
just taking or Bishop f6 kicking that
Queen back I may even want to include h5
so this is going to be a bit annoying
Bishop here Queen g4 pawn h5 this queen
is really close to being trapped
she was running very short on squares I
don't really see a reason not to do this
Bishop move
get out of there Queenie now I don't see
a fantastic discovered attack just yet
maybe I should do this first
hey I'm smelling some stuff here let's
see let's do this first she has to go
back here and what is the plan of action
now reposition by night to like hear
something or oh I could do a pawn push
ooh
the knight has to give itself up do
Knight here or even here right here
followed by a pawn push this is gonna be
deadly Queen is definitely running short
on squares Queen g3 pawn h4 and she's
toast all right what dumb well I think
I'll be able to offer some decent tips
after the game but I think I know where
white went wrong cuz a lot of these
moves have just been all forcing these
last handful of moves is there anything
better than just pawn push not really
seeing a pawn push it's like I'm netting
more than just a piece I'm getting a
holbrook now because this turns out to
be a skewer Bishop recaptures I'm on
these - these are though this is the
last how many moves this is one two
three about five moves now all very
forcing so there's pretty sure there was
a way to avoid it what am I talking
about getting the rook I'm getting the
Queen man I'm getting more than I'm
getting the whole farm here wallflower
old farm is dead now the whole farm okay
all right good game go fishing let's
flip and let's see my first suggestion
is not to give up this pond do all right
here I you you helped me out like when
you just consider the the four central
squares where we are in a sense balanced
if you view it as okay how many puns do
you have how many puns do I have we have
one each and after this exchange now you
have zero I have one but it's so much
more than that I can maybe be pressing
forward kicking this night away not
really move I was considering but I'm
really focused on f5 and also g4
this is something that you need to keep
control over maintain one of your pawns
in the center in short so I think your
Bishop does well to just react
immediately it's gonna have to react
anyhow after this so maybe maybe just go
with the immediate Bishop b5 right so
okay just go with the immediate reaction
maintain your pawn on e4 and when it
does get to this point I'm not so sure
about giving up the bishop for night
maybe maybe it is important because I
was talking about it I think just as you
played the move and that is sometimes
maybe I could like if if I just make a
passing move let's just say let's just
say Bishop D D - if I post my knight
here you take I take with check now
comes a six b5 with a six with tempo b5
with tempo c4 with tempo and your Bishop
is dead very similar to the Noah's Ark
trap where there's this pawn chain that
runs from a six to c4 so maybe you're
kind of forced into in some sense of
giving up that Bishop before it becomes
a liability
it's this is I'm pretty sure it's just
bad for white now so and a lot of it is
again attributed to the decision to take
on d5 instead of immediately playing to
b5 but just still running with this if
you are to get in this position right
here know that if you are even if just
for a moment you are to position your
pieces in a way where you're having to
babysit one of your pawns you're really
setting yourself up for a lot of bad
things to happen and the number one
thing that springs to mind for me is the
tactic of deflection I'm looking for
maybe my first thought is how can I
deflect this rook away from the defense
of the pond there's not really a way to
do that the other bad thing that happens
as a result of it is well what you saw
in the game the queen is way short on
squares and you know it's it's it's just
bad news here Knight f5 and is that
those are all forcing moves I guess if
there is something else to be done after
my Knight does play to f5 the other
Square to try is maybe just one of these
light squares right away but that's
still very scary is it now so anyhow
those are my main suggestions back here
when it comes to the decisions with the
pawns in the resulting structure keep
that guy around okay let me close